so um so we asked the following question
okay could that be the basis of cancer
and now i must say that of course we're
not the first to have this idea okay
again harold burr um had this said this
in the 30s
but so we did we did three things we
said okay first of all when this process
happens can you see using the voltage
dyes can you see the cells defecting
from the electrical network
and in fact that's then in fact you can
so what you can what you can do is you
before it happens so so you can inject a
human oncogene which is going to form a
tumor in a tadpole you inject that into
um
you inject that into a uh
into a tadpole they make a um
they make a they make a you know it
makes a tumor and even before that tumor
becomes uh becomes apparent
you can
uh you can see with a voltage dye you
can see that those cells become become
highly depolarized they electrically
uncouple from the rest of the tissue and
they go on their way and they just treat
to them the rest of the animal is just
external environment at that point so
they become electrically uncoupled and
that's that's the first thing that that
oncogenes do is electrically isolate the
cell from its neighbors from that
collection of of signals that normally
tell the cell what to do in a larger
context so that's the first thing we did
the second thing we did we said well
if that if that's a potential cause of
cancer
could we
uh could we could we cause cancer
but just by disrupting the electrical
communication directly no no oncogenes
no carcinogens no dna damage no
mutations nothing wrong with the cells
that any molecular biology
test could see
and could we still could we cause cancer
because because remember the standard
model in the field for years has been
that cancer is the cause of genetic
damage basically right that it's that
it's a genetic disruption that makes a
rogue cell that has other mutations and
so on so we said fine no we're going to
take completely normal cells nothing
wrong with them and we're going to
simply prevent them from talking to
other cells electrically okay we're just
going to manipulate that and so we did
that and sure enough we made metastatic
metastatic melanoma in tadpoles so so
that tells you that you there doesn't
have to be anything wrong with the
hardware in order to have cancer it can
be a purely physiological phenomenon it
can be caused at the software level
which a lot of people who study
stress-induced cancers and things like
this they kind of already knew but but
but really the paradigm has been that
there has to be a genetic defect at the
root of this somewhere okay and then the
third thing we found which is of course
the most exciting thing
which is you can go in the opposite
direction you can you can inject a
really powerful human occaging like a
p53 mutation oncogene for those who are
listening it's just a gene that causes
cancer yeah an oncogene is a is a
mutation in a in the normal gene that
causes that that are that is that is
thought to cause a cancer transformation
to cancer yeah okay so you can inject
that and then if you do that into into a
tadpole
if you at the same time inject an ion
channel that
forces the cell to remain in an
electrical state where it's connected to
its neighbors and it doesn't depolarize
then even though that oncogene is
blazingly strongly expressed there's no
there you you won't you won't have a you
won't have a tumor because you're
overriding that there's a hardware
problem but it doesn't matter because
you're overriding it and saying yeah i
know you want to depolarize but you
can't you have to stay connected to
these neighbors and you're just going to
be part of this and and and we can
override that way a variety of different
uh different types of oncogenes
so i was just having an analogy in my
head it's almost like imagine you have
these kids and they're misbehaved so you
can say well it's the kids who are the
problem and they cause havoc in the
house but if you have an adult who's
stern enough they can override the
misbehaved kids if you leave the kids
without the adult and the household
shambles in this analogy the adult is
like the electrical communication so you
can force that electrical communication
that standard adaptive electrical
communication
yeah yeah you can you can think of it
that way i mean the the the thing where
i think it it it breaks down a little
bit is that is that you we're not
introducing an extra element that keeps
everybody else in line right we're we're
in effect it's like um
you know it's like it's like it's like
you have a bunch of kids that know what
to do and you've got one that's wearing
uh you know dark glasses and you can't
see and he's causing all kinds of
trouble because you can't see what he's
doing well you can you can sort of you
could put a camera on him or take the
glasses off or something so that he just
goes right back into the into the
interactions with with the you know in
the in the with the rest of the uh
you know the rest of the group it's
about it's about communication it's
about
uh binding the individual competent
subunits towards a larger goal your goal
is not simply to grow as much as you can
the way an amoeba is your goal is to
build a hand or a liver or an eye or
something else it's really about the
scale up of goals and electrical
networks are great for this